welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where they all float it has been
re-released in cinemas across America
this weekend with an added post-credit
scene at the end of the movie that
showcases eight minutes of brand-new
footage from the upcoming film in
Chapter two throughout this video I'll
be breaking down what happens in the
extended look as well as giving my
thoughts on it there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything from the movie potentially ruin
for you then I highly suggest that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into my
breakdown of the in chapter 2 footage
okay so the following comes from the it
the movie reddit thread from user tpw p
ju n 20 who saw the re-release last
night the user says the footage opens
with bills showing up to the restaurant
and walking inside to find Mike waiting
in the shadows screed him they catch up
about how they've changed and before
they can sit down they're greeted by
Eddie who shows up listing all of the
food items he can't have to the waitress
including even a single walnut which
would realistically kill him
cut back to outside where Beverly is
approaching the restaurant and is
greeted from behind by a very handsome
Ben she doesn't recognize him at first
and then there's a small flash back to
the first time they talked on the last
day of school before they're interrupted
by Ritchie who exclaims you both look
great
what the f happened to me the three of
them joined the other three waiting
inside where they all sit and chat about
their differences
Ritchie cracks a few really funny jokes
called Stan a [ __ ] for not showing up
and then tells everyone how he vomited
after getting the call from Mike but not
being sure why the room goes silent and
everyone tells Ritchie they felt the
same way but could not place the feeling
Mike concludes that since they all left
dairy their memories have faded but he
stayed and he remembers it all Beverley
through tears recalls the name Pennywise
which immediately triggers a reaction
from the losers Club Mike pulls out a
notebook full of documentation of the
most recent murders
including the slaw and Adrian melon he
tells the losers that he called them
back to defeat it once and for all
because they made an oath Ritchie
cracked open a fortune cookie that reads
the word curd on it which he remarks his
weird and cheap the rest of the losers
crack open theirs to reveal four more
words which are guess cut not and it
Mike exclaims that this is the work of
it and that it's not a prank that he's
pulling on them
the losers then tried to make a sentence
out of these five words but can't make
sense of them until Beverly hands over a
piece of paper which reads Stanley bill
then slides them round to make out guess
Stanley could not cut it they all go
silent until a fortune cookie bulb
begins to violently shake a move one
cookie fall to the table bouncing around
and before a quick cut to black out pops
a small baby bird okay so there's a lot
to unpack here firstly I love the fact
that there's a reference to Adrian
Mellon who is the star of my favorite
chapter from the original book I've
already made a video that covers the
characters history and why is so
important which I'll leave linked at the
end if you want to check it out but
beyond that it also discusses Stanley's
fate for those who don't know in the
source material Mike phones all of the
losers Club one by one to ask them if
they will keep their oath and return to
Derry to kill Pennywise on the phone all
of them except including Stanley however
he starts to get flashbacks to when he
was a child and he locks himself in the
bathroom commit suicide and writes it on
the wall in blood there's been some
speculation and the movie might change
things slightly and perhaps have him
alive but this pretty much confirms that
he won't be making the reunion another
thing about this scene that is so
different is that bar the location the
majority of its events actually diff
very highly from the original work
however I actually really like the
changes it feels a lot more creepy and
fleshed out here and it's clear that
penny wise is desperate to tear them
apart as he knows that they could
ultimately be as I'm doing overall it's
a brilliant scene and I'm really looking
forward to seeing it in the film next
month and that's all of the footage from
it chapter two that was shown in the
re-release let me know your thoughts on
it in the comment section below and if
you've read the original book or have
seen the TV mini-series tell me whether
you prefer these changes or not if you
want something else too
watch that make sure you check out my
breakdown of the trailer Fortinet which
would be linked at the end I go over
everything that happens in it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
haven't seen the leaks yet and I'll also
leave my breakdown on Adrian melon after
this so you can get more of an
understanding of the character as a
thing he's going to play quite a big
role in it chapter 2 if you want to come
talk to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then you can follow me
on twitter at definition YT it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this I also just
want to let you know that we're
currently giving away a free copy of
Avengers endgame on blu-ray to one lucky
winner and all you have to do is like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on the itch aptitude footage in the
comment section below
who wouldn't all be chosen at random on
August the 10th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from then whoever gets the
prize so best of luck to everyone who
takes part as you've only got less than
a week to enter this is the channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you